hi there i hope uh this is bright enough
and that the traffic noise doesn't drown
me out
but uh here we are it's the evening time
in lisbon
our hotel is just around the corner uh a
bit tiring always with the time change
and all
and of course having been in
south america and having learned the or
having listened to so much brazilian
portuguese it takes a little while to
get accustomed again to
the portuguese that spoken in portugal
of course the amazing thing is is to
think that this country and
headquartered if you want in lisbon here
expanded
all over the globe and so whenever i go
anywhere i go straight to bookstores i
went to the fnac
and i bought this book here
and oz inventors
and it's a book in portuguese about how
the portuguese
essentially the way he describes it in
the book
connected
uh you know asia to south america to
africa to europe in a way that hadn't
been done before
this was the original globalization now
of course there had been
uh expansions before there had been i
mean uh
you know i'm heading off to morocco
tomorrow where they speak a mixture of
berber and arabic
a form of arabic i guess influenced by
the original language and why they do
that because
the arabs and the islam expanded out of
saudi arabia and conquered everything
from spain to
iran and afghanistan so there had been
all these movements but but they had all
been in sort of um separate entities i
mean we had you know uh
timberlane they went into india and the
mongols expanded and the turks took
constantinople but everything was kind
of adjacent
and it was really the portuguese that
went traveling over the ocean to connect
different parts of the world and that's
why their language is spoken in
south america and was spoken in certain
parts of asia and is spoken in different
places in africa
and but this book is very interesting
because he begins first of all by
quoting seneca the greek uh
excuse me the roman i guess he was
philosophy maybe in greek actually
who said that there is no favorable wind
for someone who doesn't have a goal
and i think that applies to language
learning like if we know what we want to
achieve and we have some sense of how to
get there we're more likely to succeed
many language learners don't really have
a sense of where they want to get to and
how to get there
but
he also makes the point
in the book the author of this book that
it could very easily have been the
chinese
that
connected the different parts of the
world that created the first
globalization because
essentially you know 50 years before the
portuguese traveled to south america
africa asia the chinese were traveling
in the indian ocean and and in asia and
i think to africa
and they had you know navigation
technology and and naval technology and
larger far superior to what the
portuguese had
and larger boats but all of a sudden
they lost interest and they decided that
this was uh all these activities
exploring activities were not going to
be
all that useful to china and they
stopped doing it but so it gets back to
my interest which our language and
history and why the world is the way it
is and it's conceivable that had the
chinese persisted that they had felt
that was in their interest
then
various parts of the world might be
speaking chinese too today instead
different parts of the world speak a
variety of uh mostly european languages
and uh the world is increasingly
globalized uh i'm not one of those who
thinks that the world will have you know
increasingly speak one language english
i think it's easier for people to learn
languages than ever before
and if anything regional languages are
being
revived so the world is increasingly
globalized but i think this is this can
be done in a way that respects the
individual cultures and traditions of of
the countries as as they now exist so
with that uh tomorrow we're off to
morocco for my
next adventure
and it's going to be a bit like me
learning mandarin in hong kong since the
people in morocco don't speak the form
of
of uh
you know arabic the standard arabic that
i'm learning
much like when i was in hong kong people
spoke only
cantonese and the lingua franca for
foreigners there is french just as
english was the lingua franca for
foreigners
uh dealing with the locals in uh in hong
kong so it'll be very interesting for me
anyway there you have it bye for now
[Music]